На роботу на Захід.
Така тенденція до трудової міграції – не лише в Україні,
але й в східних країнах Євросоюзу.
Чехам, угорцям, полякам не складно влаштуватися
на більш оплачувану роботу в межах ЄС,
тож в самих країнах – криза кадрів.
Щоб залатати дірки в багатьох галузях, деякі країни ЄС
спрощують умови працевлаштування українців.
У Чехії кількість вільних робочих місць побила рекорд — понад 260 тисяч.
Країні конче потрібні  медсестри, працівники соціальної сфери,
робітники середньої технічної кваліфікації, будівельники.
Тож чеський уряд почав розробляти програму, яка б
дозволила прискорено працевлаштовувати українців.
За угодою між Україною і Чехією, майже 20 тисяч українців
зможуть отримати право працевлаштуватися на два роки.
Нині у Чехії вже працюють 70 тисяч громадян України.
Угорщині бракує передусім програмістів, інженерів,
будівельників, водіїв, швачок, столярів, сімейних лікарів і медсестер.
Для українських фахівців у цих галузях Угорщина спростила видачу
дозволу на працевлаштування ще в липні 2016 року.
Тоді можна було з будь-якою візою приїхати в країну
і безкоштовно отримати дозвіл на роботу за один день.
"Безвіз" ще більше спростив цю процедуру.
Утім за правилами "безвізу" перебувати в країні можна лише 90 днів на півроку.
Тож для довготривалої угорської робочої візи
українець має отримати посвідку на проживання в Угорщині.
У Польщі вже працює близько мільйона українців, кажуть в МЗС України.
Державі передусім потрібні програмісти ,торгові агенти,
інженери з електромонтажу, мікробіологи, комірники,
будівельники, зварювальники та слюсарі.
Українці у Польщі, які в'їхали у країну за безвізом,
з 1 січня 2018 року мають право звертатися по дозвіл на роботу
або оформлення декларації про намір працевлаштувати іноземця.
Її реєструють роботодавці, які хочуть взяти на роботу українця.
Видається вона не більше, ніж на шість місяців на рік.
Хоча без оформлення робочої візи українець зможе скористатися
цим дозволом лише протягом 90-та днів на півроку.
В українському уряді трудову міграцію вважають
однією з найбільших загроз державі.
Утім, втримати відтік кадрів поки не вдається.
Одним з кроків стало підвищення мінімальної
заробітної платні у 2017 році до 3 200 грн
Це близько ста семи євро. Середня – удвічі більша.
Економісти називають середню зарплату у 16 тисяч гривень як таку,
що може утримати українця від заробітків за кордоном.